de visita en hoja ni los científicos de
la organización mundial de la salud
asistieron las reuniones que esperaban
desde hace mucho tiempo en los
hospitales donde fueron tratados por
primera vez casos de kobe 19 en el
instituto de biología de wuhan donde se
han estudiados numerosos casos de
coronavirus otro tipo de visitas los
expertos habrían preferido evitar como
la que hicieron a la exhibición de
propaganda que muestra lo bien que china
ha luchado contra el hobbit
su misión es encontrar los orígenes del
virus pero la ms advirtió que la gente
no debería esperar respuestas todavía
el éxito no se basa en encontrar una
fuente en la primera misión
la misión es compleja no sólo porque los
orígenes del 'hobbit' datan de hace más
de un año sino también porque hay
tensión política sobre el tema china no
quiere que el informe diga que el país
pudo haber manejado mejor la crisis y
evitado que la pandemia se extendiera
por todo el mundo matando a más de 22
millones de personas
eeuu incluso bajo la administración
bailén ha pedido una investigación
sólida advirtiendo sobre la
interferencia
en la misión lado ms dice que no tiene
una idea predeterminada sobre lo que ha
causado el coi 19 pero es poco probable
que su equipo investigue la teoría que
sugiere que el nuevo coronavirus se
filtró por accidente de un laboratorio
una idea que algunos miembros de la
misión han descartado como teoría de la
conspiración